- [Patrick Mahomes:] WELCOME TO WILD CARD WEEKEND 2021!
- We’ve got some exciting games! And also Rams-Seahawks.
Right, Pat? … Pat?
NO. WE TALKED ABOUT THIS.
- They never let me play Wild Card Weekend…
- [Aaron Rodgers:] Josh Allen keeps going all-in every hand.
- Wait, if I win I get more money?
- I’m gonna try to beat you.
- Wow, the disrespect.
- [Aaron Rodgers:] Sick Tom. Can Lamar finally win when the lights are bright?
- [Mahomes:] ♪♪♪ Bum bum. Bum bum. Bum bum. ♪♪♪
- I will destroy this narrative…hopefully.
- Years of hard work leading up to this moment...
WHY THE F--K AM I BEING SLIMED?
- [Mahomes:] Saints-Bears is brought to us by GRIDIRON HEIGHTS JR.
- [Rodgers:] All right, let's check in on these clowns.
- All in.
- [Mahomes:] Moving on. Taylor Heineken, what a story!
- [Rodgers:] And Baker gets to play without a coach. Lucky bastard.
- [Mahomes:] Oh, look! They’re already up!
- THIS IS FLUFFIN'…
Phil, you're 39 years old. This is fluffin' OK.
- I did the unthinkable. I beat Washington!
- I’M THE BETTER RUNNING BACK! Wait, no.
- How?! We were undefeated the first 11 hands.
- Tune in next week when I get to play the Rams.
- Coach.
- Cody Parkey.
- You look well.
- YOU SON OF A-